vous allez me dire ce qui se passe
maintenant
l'homme que vous cherchez s'appelle
peter a rogné pourquoi qui sait votre
père
en fait je sais pas grand chose je sais
qu'ils les généticiens un expert dans ce
qu'on appelle la biogénétique de
l'humain et qu'il a mené un programme
d'expérience vous voulez dire quoi par
expérience je veux dire du genre qui
créent des tueurs ils ont modifié des
êtres humains en choisissant et en
améliorant des gènes spécifiques
les appels sont devenus plus forts plus
rapides et plus intelligent que le
commun des mortels on les appelait des
agents qu'est ce que j'avais honte
pourquoi ils veulent me tuer brydon
technologie a redémarré le programme d
achat
il fabrique des agents en ce moment même
comme 47 ou pis encore ils pensent que
vous êtes la clé pour retrouver votre
permis
je comprends pas